ken thanks a lot for for coming out it
would really appreciate and I know a lot
of people are looking forward to this
just to pick up on guards introduction
you know you're one of the few CEOs on
Wall Street who's still at the helm post
the financial crisis in addition it
couldn't be an easy you know just months
after becoming CEO being nine eleven and
facing those challenges through all
those what have you learned about
leadership through crisis and are there
lessons that are applicable about to
day-to-day leadership yeah I think
clearly my tenure has been one where
I've had to confront some of the most
challenging crises that we've seen in
the last hundred years and one of the
mottos that I follow actually comes from
Napoleon and it's frankly a motto that I
think about frequently and it's very
simple but very hard to execute and that
is that the role of a leader is to
define reality and give hope and that's
what I think about frankly every day
because if in fact you want to have an
inspired work force you have to in fact
make sure that people understand that
you're grounded in reality
but then you have to give them the
strategies the ideas and the values that
give them reasons to be hopeful and as
we went through the 9/11 crisis
certainly we went through the crisis of
the this downturn one things that I
recognized is that it was very very
important very quickly to analyze and
then communicate what the reality of the
situation was and even if that meant
that those facts were harsh
the organization needed to understand it
investors need to understand that but
second very importantly it was critical
to in fact take what appeared to be a
very confusing situation and and this is
not meant to overly simplify problems
but what I do believe is you've got to
give people an organizing device and so
in the case of the challenges of 2008
and 2009 I had a mantra that I really
believe if you asked almost any company
in around the world for us any employee
what was the mantra' what they would say
is that stay liquid because that was
part of the reality commercial markets
were frozen the credit markets were
frozen
I thought our balance sheet was strong
but I wanted to make people understand
based on what was happening and the
financial services marketplace was state
liquid what did that mean
stay profitable and that was part of one
giving hope to the organization that
despite the fact that a number of
financial services companies were losing
money we in fact had an opportunity to
distinguish ourselves if we could be
consistently profitable every quarter
which we were and the third back to the
hope was that we were still going to
selectively invest in growth and gave
them very very specific examples of the
areas that we were going to invest in
just to pick up on that how do you in
the midst of what looks like a complete
perfect storm get people inspired to
drive for growth and invest in that and
take those risks I think part of what
you have to do again as you state what
the reality is and I'll give you some
examples from our from our business is
you got to give people some markers of
how do they judge you're making progress
because simply to go out to the
organization and say look we're we're
faced with an incredible crisis one of
the worst financial crises and 100 years
but trust me
I think I'm smart I think I'm energetic
we're gonna get through this you're
gonna say give me a break
that's that's not gonna work so what I
tried to do is one I said let's look at
the history of our company American
Express is a hundred and sixty year old
company I actually used a number of
examples through our history but in fact
was able to use some of the examples
from 9/11 because most investors had
written us off in a number of ways
and I took them through how we were able
to get through that but then I said here
are some markers that we are going to
use one is are we going to be able to
maintain the premium prices that we
charge for our card and to our merchants
because as you saw in the crisis with
the downturn and the precipitous drop in
spending so in our case from 2002 to
2007 we averaged 16% growth and Billings
which really led the market and five
quarters into the five quarters in or
five months into the downturn we had
declined in spending 16% 16% in a
negative growth in Billings people were
saying where the bottom is falling out
credit losses were increasing so I said
one is one what we want to make sure is
will customers pull their cord out of
their wallet at the same time so what's
the transaction level and frankly part
of the risk there we're saying to people
but that's where the reality is here's
how you can judge if we're gonna have
success or failure so people are pulling
their cord out of their wallet at
basically the same rate that they did
pre downturn that should give you
confidence in the future so even though
Billings have dropped 16% the loyalty to
the product is they're pulling that card
out and that was one and that was
one that we tracked and talked about to
the organization on a consistent basis
and then we're frankly some people
concerned saying Ken well if we give
some of this out what if we don't
achieve it so well that's part of the
reality then we're gonna have to come up
with strategies to ensure that we can
get people to pull their card out of the
wallet more the second thing we looked
at is we said will people trade down
because as you saw with a lot of
retailers people were trading down our
high prices and turian products which in
fact when you first get a card you got
to pay a five thousand dollar fee and
then a twenty five hundred dollar fee
every year the affluent second segment
was hit hard and we said can we hold on
to that well one is what we were pleased
about but we held that out as a metric
is that people kept their cards they did
not trade down and so so our retention
levels really stayed in very very good
shape third area which was an important
one against a liquid is it was at
certain points in time and absolutely
horrifying experience when the markets
froze up and people were very concerned
about funding so what we said at this
point was that we in fact having limited
to no experience in the deposit
gathering business that we actually were
going to focus on gathering deposits
because we were very reliant on the
wholesale funding model this is where I
think a brand is very important and
fortunately the service ethic that the
Dean talked about the reputation and the
trust that was developed was helpful to
us but we put together a very innovative
strategy and from a standing start in in
twelve months we in fact had gathered
over 26 billion dollars in deposits
taking care of our funding needs that in
fact helped the organization a great
deal then because of the uncertainty of
the environment not because we thought
we were going to go out of business
but frankly I said as an insurance
policy should we do tarp and we went
back and forth with that and we ended up
taking close to three billion dollars of
tork money which by the way we were we
were one of the first companies to repay
at a 26 percent return for the US
taxpayer which I feel very good about
I also remind people when they talk
about tarp is I said I say I don't know
about your investment portfolio but I
don't think you got a 26 percent return
investment portfolio so the the
important point there was to take some
contingencies out and to explain to
people the reasons why and then in fact
we identified areas for investment so I
think the balance is you've got to
demonstrate the strategies but then you
have to set some markers that you can
let people know about the progress on a
very regular basis as you deliver those
messages how do you get those messages
out to the broader organization and then
what are some tools or tactics you use
to actually pulse the organization so
you're not isolated in these it was good
we we do a lot of pulsing through the
organization there's obviously a lot of
informal feedback but what we have done
increasingly is to rely online on
getting that feedback because the
terrific thing is you can get questions
out very quickly we're an organization
that knows how to analyze information
and data that's one of our strengths and
so to be able to correlate some of the
drivers of satisfaction where people are
confused on an issue is absolutely
critical
we have town halls via satellite because
I think you want to have a notion that
we are one company and doing these
global town halls have been very
important
I do also as well as a number of our
senior leaders what I call brown-bag
lunches with approximately 30 employees
where I give them first sort of a three
minute here's my temperature here's how
I feel about the business then ask me
anything you want and then I say to them
always at the end of the lunch only have
one favor is I would like you to
communicate to five to ten people and
give them your impression and you can
say I think Ken's a jerk I don't know
what he was talking about it's better
that they hear it from you then they
just imagine it it would be preferable I
don't say that today and those have gone
those have gone very well but I think
basically in the world we live in today
just like marketing every single channel
you should be using face to face online
every single Channel I've read one of
the things you encourage with in MX is
this idea of constructive confrontation
right just wondering what it means for
you and if there any cost associated
with that yeah here's here's what's
important and I think you know it's
critical what you're trying to develop
in any organization is a level of
transparency and openness and honesty
and what I find in most organizations
that where things get bogged down is
when people feel that they have to game
the system in some way to get a point
across the amount of time you waste the
chances for misalignment of
priorities is a real problem and so what
what what I try to do is is to make sure
that I leverage the information that we
have about the organization that people
clearly understand what our priorities
are and I think that works very well
switching gears a little bit
you've been at American Express since
1981 which I find incredible just given
the world I see today at least where
employees switch companies a lot what
has kept you in Amex over all these
years and how is your leadership style
evolved over the years to where it is
today yeah I think what has kept me at
the company and I'll give you just a
little bit of background in a sense is I
I went to law school thinking that I
would probably practice for two or three
years and then I really wanted to go
into venture capital and this is really
going to date me but when I was coming
out cable was really the big deal that
would change the world
and so Amex had entered into a joint
venture with Warner Amex
and at the time Lou Gerstner was running
one of the major parts of the company
and
Lu had heard about me from a client that
he knew and I talked to him about
joining the planning department in a
relatively junior role but I said I
really want to work on cable and he said
we'll see if we can make that happen and
I've told this story in the past and so
Lewis heard me say this it never
happened
but but it didn't happen for some very
good reasons and one of the things that
was a particularly important point that
Lou made to me was that that Amex was a
company that was a service company but
was a very idea driven company and that
you could in fact see your ideas
implemented in a relatively short period
of time and you could impact people's
lives and for me that was one of the
important things that I believe in
business is I want to make a difference
in people's lives I like being in the
service business but I also like the
intellectual challenge that you can come
up with ideas and you can make things
happen and so this is a company that
continues to evolve in some very major
ways and as a dramatically different
company because when I joined the
company in 1981 it was on the verge of
actually becoming a financial super
market we had Lehman we had Shearson if
we had all those companies today I would
not be talking to you a very different
environment so I think ideas things that
has kept me there ideas make a big
difference
the service commitment that people have
is incredible and I often say where the
company has made strategic mistakes
what has protected the company has been
our frontline
because they really have built the
reputation of the company a number of
CEOs who've spoken here in the past to
remark that reflection and introspection
and setting aside time and space to
think and generate ideas is important
and has been important to their
leadership style just wondering how you
feel about that and what are things that
you do to kind of set that time in space
for yourself you know I you know I think
what is important is what's critical is
to make sure that you are exposing
yourselves to a range of ideas so you
had talked about constructive
confrontation which is I think about it
an answer as directly as I could this
will will actually be helpful there I
think what is important and why
constructive confrontation is so
important and why it opens up ideas is
because the status quo has to be
constantly challenged and what you want
is an environment what I want is
environment where people really feel
passionate and if you feel passionate
about things you should debate them and
you should care about them and you
should challenge each other and that
makes for an incredibly vital
environment so I will sometimes
instigate debate intentionally and go in
and frankly take a position and a point
of view that I know will stir things up
now you got to be careful because when
you see oh yeah what you know what's the
deal so you have to be careful in doing
that but what is critical is there are a
lot of terrific ideas at every level of
a company and so you want to set up the
mechanisms again through every channel
to do that but the tone has to be set at
the top that you in fact are the type of
person that people feel comfortable
arguing with you on issues
I always then make the point however
that once we decide on a course of
action we can't then have people
continuing to debate we
to move forward then the other thing
that I try to do is to reach outside the
company and and I've put together like a
pretty worldwide network of people that
I check in with a fair amount online
some of it on the phone some of it in
person that really bring out some
different perspectives so it may not be
that they give you the brilliant idea
but they give you a different way of
thinking about an issue that helps you
come up with that idea I'm sure I've
done other places where you spoke and
you've commented that mentoring is
important to you and I was just
wondering if you'd speak to who who've
been some of your mentors along the way
and who inspires you as a leader today
good oh I'll talk about two or three
mentors that I'll have and then the
other point I'll make about mentoring
because I think it's sometimes is
misunderstood what I really believe is
that if you want to develop to develop a
true mentor relationship and you want to
network you want to network off of your
performance just in fact to meet someone
is generally not that helpful because
here's sort of how the trade works at
least for me is if I'm gonna take on a
mentee and I really do like to help
people and work with people in
developing it's one of the most
satisfying parts of leadership I want to
get something in return I want to be
stimulated by the ideas that they can
come up with and the dialogue I want
in fact for them to have the commitment
that they're going to really improve in
the areas that they need to improve on
and that they're capable really making
things happen that's that's that's part
of the trade off and I think when you
look at a mentor at different levels
sometimes you're looking for someone who
can give you technical advice
that's not a mentor to me that's an
expert and that's very important to seek
out that expert advice what I look for
in mentors is really judgment because
that to me at the end of the day from a
leadership standpoint is is is really
the toughest challenge and so over the
years I've had a diversity of mentors
and and I'll talk about them in two
categories one is there's the obvious
senior mentor and a few of the people
that I would put in that category for me
is Warren Buffett is a mentor I've been
fortunate that he is our largest
investor but we've also developed a very
good professional and personal
relationship what I know with Warren is
that performance matters a big deal he's
a very nice man but do not think at all
that performance is not what it's about
but but what is most impressive with
Warren for me is this combination of his
intellect and his values and how he
approaches an issue and how he has a
criteria that really is one of balanced
of someone who wants to be incredibly
successful do very well in his
investments but at the same time he
really wants to do the right thing and
how he approaches issues have been
impressive early on in my career Lou
Gerstner was a very important mentor to
me hard driving rigorous objective and I
really learned a lot from him and Harvey
Gallup
was someone who had the ability to
analyze issues and really drive down
through the details and never assumed
because someone was telling him a view
when Harvey's favorite comments was
always is that a fact or is that your
perspective and that just is a useful
discipline because sometimes people get
the two confused
so I've really tried to pick different
qualities from the mentors the other
part of mentorship is that is important
though is I've had a lot of mentors in a
structural sense that have been at lower
levels in the company and and I also
make this point that what you get with a
mentor that's a lower level is it a
lower level in a company is an
unfiltered perspective in the sense that
they'll tell you who the phonies are in
the company it really is amazing because
they've been there because people take
liberties with people that they don't
think are senior and and I really have
developed relationships with people
because again remember my criteria for a
mentor his advice in judgment and their
people at lower levels who have
incredible judgment and incredible
insight that coming up through the
company helped me tremendously to say
you know at the end of the day here are
some people you should stay away from
because you can't trust them
for these reasons seeing him in these
situations or watch out for this
situation or you may be approaching an
issue in this way here's another way to
think about it and so I really encourage
people to develop mentors at different
levels of the organization before we
open it up to the audience I had a
personal question if you don't mind
unemployed MBA student as wondering if
you'd help me qualify for this insuring
card
i shameless ask I think I can help but
unless you meet the criteria I don't
think I'm gonna have much of an impact
but I can advise you on how you can
perform - certainly we see I'll take you
up on that yes
with that we'd love to open up I believe
their mics along or already planted
thank you for your son thank you for
your speech
just had a quick question about Amex is
undoubtedly known as kind of the
flagbearer within the financial services
industry when it comes to card member
satisfaction and and premier customer
servicing so my question is kind of
moving forward when it comes to this
this Premier servicing and satisfaction
what are your thoughts on sort of the
next wave and what is what is Amex doing
to kind of get ahead of the curve is the
you know traditional Centurion platinum
style of servicing going to be relevant
to sort of the next wave of
high-net-worth individuals here's what's
important and important as as you look
at our company because we have been
traditionally identified with what we
call the issuing business that we issue
a range of cards the reality is that
service is important in every area but
what you have to do is segment that
value proposition of service in a very
customized way and that's what we are
doing however when you look at our
company and I'll talk about just a few
of the areas that I think are very
exciting going forward we are more than
just a payments company if you said can
what what really is your company about
what we do is we facilitate value to a
range of segments using the payments
vehicle but what we're not is a
commodity payments company so I'll just
give you a few examples that will
illustrate this point one is if you look
at the payments landscape and you say
who's on who's in the issuing business
we are in the issuing business in terms
of bill
were the largest issuer in the world 620
billion dollars in Billings last year
however we also are a network processor
similar to Visa and MasterCard and we're
a global network processor but our card
member which helps our value proposition
of merchants spends three to four times
the size of average spend of Visa and
MasterCard the third piece that were on
is that we actually acquire merchants
which Visa and MasterCard don't fourth
piece is in rewards and loyalty we are
actually one of the largest loyalty
companies in the world now the fact that
we have information unlike any other
person in payments company and payments
we have information and data on the
issuing side of the business and we have
information and data on the merchants
side of the business information as we
all know is power so as we go forward
and this is some of the things that we
are doing now is one
business-to-business represents a
tremendous opportunity and we are one of
the leading payment companies in
business-to-business but the value
proposition we're offering companies is
we're just not saying we're going to
facilitate your transaction we're saying
to them we actually can help you reduce
your expenses using our products and
services and so we have inner adventures
with concur and a range of companies
because that's part of what we can do is
facilitate that value to drive it we
think that presents substantial
opportunity emerging payments we made an
acquisition of a company called
revolution money that is has some
similar capability to PayPal because I
believe person a person is going to be
important I believe Mobile is going to
be very important we are doing a deal
right now with ICBC the largest bank in
China and you and pay the largest mobile
provider where we have a mole
payments capability but what we're
increasingly doing is using our
information management capabilities to
drive additional value for our customers
so a few things that might surprise you
Darden Restaurants is one of the largest
restaurant chains in the country they
rely heavily on our data to cite their
their restaurants that they're going to
put up why because we have a range of
data of spending which we aggregate we
don't violate privacy laws but we're
using that information they pay us a
monthly fee that is a very attractive
area we're doing that for more and more
companies we have a deal with AT&T
Wireless because our customers travel
all over the world so you connect the
modeling with that with roaming
opportunities and that's major if you go
on the Delta Airlines site now for their
loyalty program the company that is
managing the site the marketing and the
merchandising is us now the important
part of that from a virtual circle
standpoint is that we in fact believe
that the opportunity with our
information to connect online and
offline is tremendous because we not
only know habits and preferences and
sites where people go but we actually
know if the transaction was consummated
so emerging payments and alternative
payments is going to be important for us
because we now have what I call
horizontal scale across the payments
landscape that is going to help us drive
that business so what I see for us is
that increasingly you're going to see a
melding of what we're doing and what I
call the broad category of servicing in
a range of businesses that will help
facilitate value for a number of online
and offline companies and we're going to
leverage and optimize the data we have
more and the and the partnerships and
our customer connections more than ever
however the hallmark has to be that I
believe particularly in the uncertain
environment that we're in and you look
at the importance of reputation is that
Trust is going to be even more important
and we know it's even going to be more
important online and that's where
service comes in your time with us today
you've remarked that leadership needs to
be consistently worked on in order to
attain the followership needed to be
successful you cited at the time
improving your listening skills what are
you working on now and what would you
say is the most important skill for us
to develop GSB in light of the changing
economy
is what I would say I think first I'll
go with what are the important skills
then I'll tell you what I'm working on
which is always a range of things and I
really do believe if you want to be a
strong leader you've got to constantly
work on areas I think that what is
absolutely critical for a leader today
is the ability to connect the dots
you can't remain alone in your
discipline what you've got to understand
is how things enter relate what are the
connections and then what are the
relevant value drivers for your business
so the ability to in fact take in a
broad set of facts and knowledge and to
see what the connection is to your
particular business is critical and so
that means at the end of the day
awareness of what is going on in the
world and trends and constantly saying
what does this development mean for my
business in my customer because at the
end of the day if you want to be a
market leader and innovate you actually
have to come to conclusions that most
people don't
and most people don't because they take
a conventional view of what they're
working on so that ability to connect is
critical for me what I'm particularly
focused on now is the BRIC countries and
part of what I'm doing from a
development standpoint is while I'm
learning a lot about the business issues
I'm actually spending a fair amount of
time through history books trying to
understand some of the culture and the
psychology in the markets that we're
operating in because I think that it is
easier to have a view of some of the
technical issues but if you want the
type of emotional engagement and one
things that I think is critical in the
marketing of products is this balance be
between rational value and emotional
connection and if in fact people really
believe that I understand who you are
and I actually respect how you think and
that can make an incredible difference
so that's one of the areas that I'm
working on
yeah um thank you very much for your
talk my name is Christopher frizzy I'm
an MBA one you draw this picture of the
great investor you have who wants to do
well and at the same time right
can you from your point of view give us
or elaborate on how do you define you
are doing right you are in an industry
where Trust is important you mentioned
the data and sensitive data you have and
where's the CEO you actually draw the
line in your company and be this person
that says we can't do this because it's
not right yeah I think one of the most
critical responsibilities of a CEO is to
understand how to draw that line and
when to draw that line and very frankly
it's very easy to articulate in a broad
way that you are a principled person
where the rubber meets the road is how
did you act so I'll give you a few
examples five years ago we did a
competitive analysis in the card
business and we said what are all the
drivers of revenue that our competitors
are using and what we found was that
there was a substantial reliance on
back-end fees and a range of practices
that frankly would have generated a
substantial amount of money and I'm
being circumspect here but it was very
very substantial and and most of our
competitors were in fact engaged in some
of those practices and many were engaged
in in most of them we actually were very
clear that we could dramatic
even more improved the financial
performance of the company but we said
we don't think that's right and we said
and I said I don't think it's right for
the following reasons
is I developed when I was running our
card businesses what we use in the
company we have three operating
principles one is provide superior value
for the customers and clients that we
choose to serve second do it in a way
that allows us to achieve best-in-class
economics and everything we must support
the brand then we have a set of values
for the company what was clear is that
one
we felt that those practices were not
consistent and we articulated that to
the team of why we were not going to
pursue it we went through in general and
we went through one by one and we said
this is this is the trade off this is
what we stand for as a company and there
are a number of examples where you're
faced with a situation where you know
one and these are the toughest issues
it's legal it's really not a problem I
mean so the ethical legal issues I mean
if you're gonna do something that's
wrong you got a problem but where you
have a situation where it's not it's
perfectly legal everyone's doing it why
not and the question is what is the
commitment we were in a situation just
this year every major financial services
company basically decided that they
would cut their dividend and and we
talked about it and every every banker
that would come in investment banker
would say can everyone's doing it it's
really not any pressure and I said look
you gotta understand with our company we
really have this concept
promises to keep and unless I thought
the company was really going under I
just don't think we should do this that
wasn't illegal wasn't wouldn't be
anything wrong morally if I did that but
the question is what were the values of
the company and what's the commitment
that you need to make it I don't
criticize another company for cutting
their dividend but for us I didn't think
that was the right thing to do
um I'm wondering in your 30 years at
American Express what you think you've
you did differently both early and later
in your career in terms of both within
your job and then within the within the
sphere of doing things to sort of
further longer-term objectives that that
resulted in you being CEO today you know
I think and it's I would say it's more
it's been more that my behavior has
evolved rather than a radical change but
I'll give you a few examples that I
think were helpful to me and what I
would caution with all advice you've got
to personalize it and you've got to
customize it to your own situation one
is what has always excited me is they're
always wanting to work with really
bright people who I thought had good
values and would allow me to do exciting
things I never came to the company with
the intent that I would become CEO
really it was until two or three years
before I became president remember
Harvey saying to me you know I think you
could run the company it really was not
not that I was naive but that just was
not the objective for me and and I think
it's important that your personal
ambition does not overcome you so that
allowed me to be independent to take
risks and help me develop a perspective
that I thought I was focused on here are
things that are not only right for the
company but here are things that I want
to do doing them in a in a team concept
so I'm not a lone ranger but at the same
time not just focused on myself the
second is that I've always believed that
you should focus on what are some ideas
that can really change
the status quo in the business and and
one of my first jobs which was a lot of
fun for me and was a big risk is we had
a business that sold merchandise through
the mail now if you think about what's
happening in the online world
segmentation information analysis and
whatever this was terrific preparation
but it was losing money and no one who
was regarded as high potential wanted to
go into that business I actually thought
that that channel was exciting and again
at that time since I didn't believe I
was going to be a big company for a long
time I said this would be a great
entrepreneurial experience when I run my
own business so let me get in and learn
about this direct marketing channel they
sell a wide variety of products but we
came up with some very innovative ideas
in how to merchandise and in a two or
three year period we went from 100
million 800 million in sales and we
developed some sourcing strategies we
went over to Asia in Japan and we had a
deal that I was able to work out with
some of the top manufacturers that they
would let us have a new product for 90
to 120 days and we'd sort of tested for
him and then they could go retail with
it
and that worked out great for us and
helped us get some decent margin because
in that business you're always pressed
on the margin side I also was very
involved in the development of our
loyalty program and saw the power of
what that could do and rewards has made
a major difference for the company so I
like strategy a lot but I also like to
implement but what's most important is I
really like changing the paradigm and I
think that helped me tremendously the
third and I hesitate even saying this
because this can be self-serving
but I think if you really want to build
leadership what's most important at the
end of the day and the first thing I
look for and try to analyze with people
is integrity and in my definition of
integrity it's not just being honest
it's what's the consistency of words and
actions and overtime what people saw in
the organization certainly is not that I
was perfect because as I said I would
have strong views if I thought sometimes
at meetings I've gotten better that
their comments were not particularly
insightful I would not necessarily
listen carefully to those comments I
have been told I've improved a lot in
that area over time and I and I think I
have but what I did develop a reputation
for in the company was a consistency of
words and actions and that helped me to
develop a follower ship and get the
emotional engagement that you need is a
leader hi is this okay the concept of
constructive conflict really stuck out
to me and from the outside you can see
the value of conflict in situations but
when you're actually inside and you're
hearing negative ideas or embracing the
heck conflict it can be really
uncomfortable and people can get quite
defensive so I was just wondering how
you have been able to turn those
negative thoughts and emotions into a
positive aspect for the company and use
it to really motivate performance yeah
here's and let me be very clear as this
is a ongoing effort in the company and I
would certainly not put us yet at the
level that I'd like to be at because to
your point it is the hardest thing to
make happen we're a company that I think
is very driven for results but what we
have always
not done historically and we've improved
a lot in this is to confront each other
so what I say
in Amex speak and I use this often in
the organization and I would when we
started off on this around ten years ago
is I would say when you hear someone say
at Amex I don't mean to disagree with
you what they're really saying is I
totally disagree everything in my power
to make sure this doesn't happen so that
was extreme but the reality is that the
sort of behavior rules that were set up
is I want open and constructive
confrontation here's what that means
you've got something to say say it at
the meeting and if it's outside the
meeting and so the first few times when
we put this in and more than a few times
you'd have sort of the usual behavior of
people would have the meeting they go
through issues circle back ken let me
tell you I really have a concern what
so-and-so said and I Suz me let's call
up so-and-so no no don't we're gonna
call them up so-and-so come in the
office so-and-so said well why don't you
say it the meeting and then I said look
now let's respect each other so what I
don't want when we disagree that you
necessarily say I think you're a jerk
what you can say is look I disagree with
the idea but personal respect is
critical but don't hesitate to be very
direct in saying why you have the issue
how you're thinking about the issue
because that's gonna bring out better
ideas and it is uncomfortable but I will
tell you in every single area one of the
most difficult things to accomplish is
the transition of CEOs ones I did with
with Harvey which was great from a
constructive confrontation said Harvard
let's take two days and let's go through
of issues what is it in the transition
you're gonna do what am I gonna do what
what do we agree on what do we not
and sometimes those sessions get heated
sometimes but the end of the day was
done with really very strong personal
directness and the behavior was very
well done so I think you can be direct I
think he can be honest I think you can
raise your voice and part of the
counseling I give to people as they go
through is sometimes you may want to
Telegraph and I'll say to someone you
know I'm gonna I really feel strongly
about this so I am gonna argue in a very
vociferous way don't take it personally
but understand this is something that is
really meaningful and so what I what I
don't want to leave you with the
impression with is that constructive
confrontation is taking place everywhere
and it's at the level but is something
that I am relentless about in the
organization because you waste so much
time I mean if we're everything is
moving so fast paced in this world that
if you have people saying another phrase
we used to use is let's take this
offline take it offline right take it
offline let's talk about it right here
so you know it's it's it's it's very
very important the more you can get
people engaged and talking to the issues
what it actually says is that I respect
you and your ideas and the fact that you
are impassioned about those ideas and
you're willing to take some risk because
that's what it takes in business is you
gotta put some risk out there if you're
gonna be careful then we're not gonna
move forward as a company we're not
gonna be a leader
last question
hi my name is Regina cross and I'm an
MBA one had a question with respect see
some learning that you have with the
BRIC countries you mentioned that you're
focused on the traditions and culture
and history and just wondered kind of
maybe what the top one or two things are
that you have learned so far with your
research and how you are working within
your organization to be able to meet the
needs and that the the variances within
the culture in our new Sims 2 or 3 and
some of these are pretty basic but there
is a strong view that the u.s. looks
down on everyone and can be patronizing
and the issue that I think is important
and one of them's that I've learned is
in fact if you're meeting someone and
people really believe and you tell them
I actually read a book about your
country I read some history about it so
the step back I found say that's pretty
unusual I mean really it's it's I just
came back from a week trip in the the
Mid East and went to a number of
countries and I wasn't able to read up
on everyone but whether it was a dinner
meeting or a lunch meeting letting
someone know that I knew something about
the politics of the country I knew
something about the economic environment
I may have known a particular history
point lets people know just as you're
forming some type of personal engagement
that you take them seriously and that
you think that their country is
important and they even learn something
and so the biggest learning in a sense
to me is just as you would any business
problem to go into a country and you're
running off the plane and you might
someone look brief me about a few things
that are happening here is not exactly
going to endear you to the people that
you meet with because they gonna say
it's all superficial we know what
they're about this is the deal but if
they say boy this person actually took
time and and there's no problem
admitting that look I'm a neophyte I
don't have I've only been to the country
once or twice or whatever but to show
real engagement and remember giving some
feedback to one of our people where we
went into a market and the person wanted
to take him to a place that he thought
was very special in his country person
said I think I'll go back to the hotel
it's been a long trip
a little bit tired I don't think that
helps
you